it's a manufacturing system all of life
is a way to create copies of things or
to replicate information including
storage of information actually hard
drives are probably one of the worst
ways for long-term storage dna might end
up being the best way to have you know
millennia or you know even longest scale
storage where you want something that
has redundancy that's built in
and it can store and can be put at
really cold temperatures and survive
even cosmic rays or so i think it
dna might be the best hard drive of the
future potentially
this is really interesting okay what is
dna
what is rna
and what are genes yes we should because
most i presume the audience knows it but
some might just be first time listeners
kind of there's a person right now who's
like in in brazil smoking a joint
sitting on the beach
and just wants to learn about dna so
please yes please do you explain it
dna the dxc ribonucleic acid is the
recipe for life it is what carries the
instructions in almost all of your cells
you have a copy of your genome it's
actually the reason i became a
geneticist is because the day i learned
that as an embryo we started just a
single cell but all the instructions
there to make every single type of cell
in your body
i was and still am endlessly fascinated
by that that is extraordinary that is
to me the most beautiful thing in the
entire universe that is a completely
from one single embryo everything is
there to make the entire body which
aspect of that is most beautiful so is
it that there's this information within
dna that's stored efficiently
and it also stores information on how to
build not just what to build
yeah and so from all of that is what's
what's the sexiest what's the most
beautiful aspect is it the entire
machinery or is it just the information
is there
it's the fact that the machinery is the
information like that they basically it
becomes its own manufacturer
is is what is extraordinary imagine if
you if you took a one two by four and
you threw it on the ground and you said
i'll be back in a day and then a whole
house was made when you came back i mean
we would all lose our minds a lot of
people would poop their pants people
would have to wear adult diapers it
would be a big scene yes if that
happened um and we're not we're actually
getting close to that people having
autonomous house building it's not quite
there yet but there are people trying to
make
uh robots that will build entire houses
but you need much more than the block of
wood right right that's that's the
extraordinary thing is just one one
piece of wood there and say i'll just
leave it there for a few days and i'll
come back that's basically what embryos
do okay it takes nine months a little
bit longer but still
that is nothing short of magic right so
i think
that's what i
love about you know the fact that dna
carries that information now the
information is static so to actually
read that information and to actually
put into motion is where rna comes in so
this ribonucleic acid so it just has one
other oxygen added to it versus dna but
it is the transcribed version it's like
if you look at a book and you say you
can have it in your hands but then you
start to read it aloud it becomes the
active form of the recipe for life is
the rna and those rnas also then get
translated to become proteins that
become active forms like enzymes you
think of like your hair or think of
other ways you digest food there's all
these you know active proteins going
around that are copying your dna making
rna making sure your dna is safe this is
all these built-in systems to keep your
cells in check and working and these are
often in protein form
and so genes are the really these
constructs basically what are the
instruction sets like how many versions
of instructions do you have in your
genome so the genome is the collection
of all the dna of a person for humans
about three billion letters of genetic
code so just three billion ac's g's and
t's these nucleotides that are the
recipe for life and that's it that is
the entire instruction set to go from
that one embryo up to a full human which
is pretty efficient to say that's
actually not that that much information
and in that three billion letters are
snippets of the genes which are
independently regulated
autonomous instruction sets if you will
these really active forms of of the the
instructions from your dna to say make a
protein make this rna or turn off some
other part of a cell all those
instructions are there in our dna and
there's about 60 000 of these genes that
are in our genome so how do those all
lead up to you
having a personality
good memory and bad memory
some of the functional characteristics
that we at the human level are able to
interpret
the
the the way your face look the way you
smile
you're good at running or jumping
whether you're good at math and all
those kinds of things there's a age-old
debate of nature versus nurture so like
most things if given two options you can
of course have both so almost every
trait
that we know of in humanity has mixtures
of nurture and nature some of them are
purely nurture so there's most people
probably familiar with twin studies but
twin cities are one of the best ways to
gauge how much is something nurture
versus nature how much of it is really
ingrained and has probably less ability
to change versus how much can you really
train so
height for example is one of the most
obvious inheritable traits but it
doesn't have one gene it probably has at
least 50 or 60 genes that contribute to
height so it's not like a gene for
height uh some people think of like the
gene for cystic fibrosis now that's in
that case that's true there is one gene
that if you have mutations you get
cystic fibrosis as a disease but for
other other traits they're much more
complicated they can have dozens or even
hundreds of genes that influence your
risk and what appears but from twin
studies you take monozygotic twins twins
that are identical and you can clearly
tell they look they have the same facial
structure similar intonation similar
even likes and you compare them to
dizygotic twins or when you have
fraternal twins you can have a male and
female for example in the same uterus
and those are you know dizygotic twins
or two zygotes so in that case they're
they sure 50 of their dna but they
shared the same womb and that and then
what you can look at is they you know
what's the difference between identical
twins versus fraternal twins and
calculate that difference for any trait
and that gives you an estimate of the
heritability or what's called h squared
so that's what we've been doing for
almost every trait in humanity for the
past you know 100 years i've been trying
to measure this and religion is one
that's a negative control so if you
separate people and see what religion
they become there's no gene for religion
or what religion you choose so that
often is their correlation there is zero
because it should be it's a nurture
trait of what religion you end up taking
is not encoded in your dna
religion meaning
islam judaism christianity
but there could be aspects of religions
that there is a good good question there
is religiosity as a trait yes there's
been study influences and that has a
heritable component to some degree
so and things like boredom
susceptibility is a trade one of my
favorite papers just looked at how
likely is it that people get bored and
they look at identical twins and
fraternal twins and there's a
heritability about 30 so it's not it's
mostly not heritable it's like mostly
environmental but that means to some
degree whether or not you're bored you
can say well it's a little bit of my
genes you could a little bit not a lot
but you know most of some degree and
they're probably overlapping with other
traits yeah boredom susceptibility
versus risk seeking behavior are
interrelated so how likely are you to
say i want to go you know cliff jumping
or i want to go i'm going to do
freebasing or i want to i don't know do
something else it's risky behavior